Film Courage: Kathie, what is then difference
between a low and high-concept movie?
And which one favors new writers?
Kathie Fong Yoneda: I think that the low-concept
favors new writers only because I think studios
in general are more willing to take a chance
on something that maybe is lower in budget.
But concept and budget are two different things.
A high-concept movie usually means a higher-concept
budget in general and that would be like your
action pictures, your super-hero pictures,
things like STAR WARS.
Things that have what they call the “tentpole”
(you’ve probably heard that term before)
a tentpole effect…it’s just a lot different.
And most of them you’ll notice are based
on something that has been adapted from another
piece of material like comics, a book, novels,
that kind of thing.
But for new people (new writers coming in),
writing a nice project that is in another
arena that doesn’t require a huge budget
and a lot of special effects, that’s a way
to really get a sense of can they develop
characters?
Can they carry a story all the way through
for 90 minutes to 100 minutes?
And can they give us good roles that actors
want?
So I think that is better, if you try and
do a lower-budget, lower-concept in terms
of genre.
That’s the way to do it.
Film Courage: Just a reminder, what is the
definition of high-concept and low-concept
again?
Kathie Fong Yoneda: Well high-concept usually
means something that you can do a lot more
with it in terms of whether it can be sequels
or prequels.
Those tend to be more high-budget and more
high-concept in terms of it’s a larger world,
more characters and they can do (like I said)
more with it.
They can continue on an adventure with all
of those characters.
So that’s why a lot of them you’ll see
are adapted from other pieces of material.
Film Courage: What’s a good test if someone
thinks their script is high-concept?
How can they run it through some tests because
maybe they’ll find out it’s actually low-concept
and they’re just not aware?
Kathie Fong Yoneda: I think genre is one way.
If you look at the ones that usually make
the most money or that are based on other
pieces of material, a lot of times they fall
into science-fiction, horror, fantasy or sci-fi
fantasy.
Those are the most popular genres for that.
Certainly if you look at things that are action
adventure like THE BOURNE IDENTITY, that’s
another one that you can do a lot with because
there is always going to be a new adventure
as this guy [Jason Bourne] is trying to find
out his real identity.
Question for the Viewers: Should new writers
focus on high-concept or low-concept?